from biblical symbolism to public
meltdowns to misleading negotiations a
lot has gone into the history of two and
a half men and you'll never believe one
risque favor john cryer actually asked
of his co-star
it isn't unusual for pilots to feature
different actors from the final cast
announced for a series quite often these
standalone episodes act as a proof of
concept and no one can predict if a
network will pick the series up
in fact many pilots go completely
unaired in the case of two and a half
men the original pilot most chicks won't
eat veal featured blythe danner in the
role of evelyn harper the matriarch of
the family despite the pilot's success
the emmy award-winning actress didn't
stick around when the sitcom was picked
up by cbs according to showrunner chuck
lori the role just wasn't perfect for
the actress so she was replaced by
holland taylor
you stay out of this i'm here to help
your brother through a very difficult
time
how could you do this to me however some
rumors suggest that danner was actually
dismissed after she insisted on making
changes to some scenes that didn't sit
well with the producers of the show
replacing a star like charlie sheen
isn't easy yet the show was determined
to soldier on without him and sign up
another actor to star alongside jon
cryer in two and a half men before
ashton kutcher hopped on board there
were several other actors being
considered for the sitcom one of the
biggest names mentioned was hugh grant
who was reportedly offered a sizable
paycheck for the role according to
deadline
in an interview with howard stern grant
revealed that he was contacted about a
part on the show but turned it down he
explained that at the time he was
offered the part the showrunners had not
written a script with the new character
and asked grant to take a leap of faith
to accommodate their production schedule
despite being a fan of the show grant's
caution prevailed and he declined the
part they make brilliant tv shows really
but i said i'm too scared to sign up
without a script he joked to stern that
he does regret not getting the paycheck
when he realized how much tv stars
earned in the us
charlie sheen's departure from two and a
half men was quite the event making
headlines around the world and inspiring
a generation of quality memes and
hashtags in the years afterward though
many fans held on to a glimmer of hope
that he'd patch up his differences with
chuck lori and have one last rodeo on
the show as it turns out he nearly did
for the series finale the producers
reached out to him about a potential
appearance the plan was always to drop a
piano on charlie harper's head however
sheen wasn't interested in this
particular ending pitching his own
suggestion a scene that sets up a
spin-off sitcom called the harpers which
would have starred him and jon cryer
after the debacle that happened between
sheen and everyone else involved on two
and a half men let's just say that no
one jumped at his idea
so the episode went ahead with lori's
original ending and without a cameo from
sheen
while two and a half men focused on the
shenanigans caused by charlie and alan
harper the heart of the show was jake
who was played by angus t jones from his
pitch perfect comedic timing to his
undisputed chemistry with his
illustrious co-stars the nine-year-old
jones took all the acclimation right
from the get-go you get no allowance
that's your punishment for gambling told
you you'd do that
yeah you did
fans might expect that the casting for
the part of jake was a long arduous
process but it wasn't in fact chuck lori
told foundation interviews that jones
was the first and only child actor to
audition for the role the showrunner
added that he had seen jones performance
as hunter morris in 2002's the rookie
and invited him to read for the role of
jake after seeing how much fun jones was
having in the audition process and how
nonchalant he was about the whole thing
the decision to cast him was an easy one
it's no secret that the line where
charlie sheen ended and charlie harper
began was a blurred one at times many
fans didn't know if sheen was simply
playing a character or himself however
there was a particular moment off-screen
when the actor acted exactly like his tv
personality by lending a hand to john
cryer in his time of need in his
autobiography so that happened cryer
admitted that he was in a difficult
place after his divorce he decided to
hire a sex worker and sheen provided his
co-star with expert advice on the
industry pryor went on to explain
charlie suggested a few online purveyors
he occasionally used as this was when
prostitution was gaining a foothold on
the internet he and i had different
tastes so i didn't go with his exact
recommendations in another case of life
imitating art crier revealed that he
once brought a girlfriend to the set
only to be told by sheen that he'd dated
her in the past and that they'd broken
up because she wouldn't allow him to
bring another partner into the
relationship when ashton kutcher joined
two and a half men it surprised many
people including the actor himself
kutcher was a big movie star who was
proving himself a bankable name in the
industry so returning to the sitcom
world where he got his start seemed like
a backward move in an interview with
howard stern kutcher disclosed exactly
what swayed his decision to take the
role of walden schmidt his previous
agent worked for william morris
endeavour a company that was heavily
involved with two and a half men
at the time kutcher was considering
signing on the show was on track for
syndication if it was renewed for two
more seasons everyone involved could
expect a very nice payday kutcher
revealed that when he found out charlie
sheen was making 1.8 million dollars an
episode he told his agent he'd take the
job if he could get a similar deal
reportedly kutcher didn't get the same
offer as sheen but the rate he was
offered was clearly lucrative enough to
attach him to the sitcom for a full four
seasons i made a billion dollars doing
this billionaire entrepreneur walden
schmidt made his debut in season nine of
two and a half men where he buys charlie
harper's beach house and becomes allen's
new best friend and eventual husband
according to ashton kutcher though the
character of walden evolved quite a bit
in an interview on wtf with mark maron
kutcher explained that when he met with
chuck lorre to discuss the part of
walden lori pitched a character very
different from the walden that wound up
making it on screen
the actor never revealed the changes
made to the character between the pitch
and the first script but he did bring up
this observation to lorry the showrunner
told him walden's character arc was
going to take some time to unfold so
kutcher put faith in lori's vision and
went along for the ride
seeing how hit sitcoms such as will and
grace and matt about you have received
revivals in recent years many fans are
wondering if there's a chance that two
and a half men could get the same
treatment especially with the original
trio reprising their iconic roles while
charlie sheen has pushed for it with the
harper's concept jon cryer isn't exactly
rushing back to the malibu beach house
anytime soon when asked about his
current relationship with sheen on
access crier stated it's kind of a
roller coaster when you have charlie in
your life and i just haven't decided to
get back on that roller coaster maybe he
needs a few extra zeros on a new
contract to help twist his arm
there were several supporting characters
on two and a half men but none of them
had the charisma or hilarity of berta
the housekeeper whether she was pointing
out the obvious or sticking around to
laugh at the harper fallouts the
outspoken berta never missed a beat
however the character could have been
very different if it wasn't for the late
conchata farrell's desire to do things
her own way in an interview with the av
club farrell explained that the
showrunners had asked her to adopt an
eastern european accent when playing the
character when she went in for the
audition she told the room that despite
the fact that she can do a pretty solid
russian accent she thought that adopting
a quote trailer park dialect was a
better fit for the character next thing
i know i'm bellying up on the floor
hacking out along while the cops are
dragging out bonnie and claude in
handcuffs farrell's performance
impressed chuck lorre and everyone else
who decided to go along with her
suggestion in fact they loved it so much
that they extended her presence on the
show far beyond the initially planned
two episode arc while the spotlight was
firmly on charlie sheen during his
ongoing feud with chuck lorre hardly
anyone ever considered what the
showrunner went through as their
conflict unfolded entertainment weekly
reports that laurie was deeply hurt by
the ordeal so much so that he
contemplated leaving two and a half men
in 2011. laurie recounted a conversation
he had with other showrunners to tv
guide i offered to quit the show last
winter i said listen if for some reason
i'm now the antichrist i'm happy to
leave it's not in my interest to stop
the show and i certainly don't want to
put all these people out of work keep
going get another guy don't stop on my
account however cbs had lori's back and
he described the network's decision to
fire sheen as a choice based on ethics
rather than money personal and
professional disagreements are common in
any industry including television
sometimes one party just might not be
feeling a script or the direction in
which the series is going they can even
part ways because of creative
differences but still remain friends
unfortunately charlie sheen didn't get
that memo not only did he burn his
bridges with chuck lori but he also
painted the town red with metaphorical
tiger blood while it appeared that sheen
would never squash his feud with lori
time does heal all wounds in an
interview with the guardian sheen was
asked about his regrets the first thing
he said was that he should have handled
leaving two and a half men more
thoughtfully
he also admitted to people that there
were numerous approaches he could have
taken to handle the conflict and that
he's unhappy with the one he chose
is it possible that by sheen admitting
his wrong he and laurie could work
together again in the future anything is
possible in hollywood
charlie sheen's departure from two and a
half men could have played out like a
scene from the show bad vibes and verbal
jabs were thrown around in the press
like a game of hot potato one of the
people who caught some collateral damage
in the process was ashton kutcher for
all intents and purposes he'd done
nothing wrong by accepting the role of
walden schmidt in the sitcom however
that didn't stop sheen from taking to
twitter and insulting kutcher on several
occasions
kutcher didn't take the attacks lying
down though and fired back when required
after a while sheen's comments stopped
bothering him completely charlie's seen
his become like a
parent on charlie brown to me it's more
like wah
years later sheen apologized and
admitted that he shouldn't have behaved
the way he did towards kutcher sheen
told the kyle and jackie o radio show i
was stupidly mean to him because i
overlooked the reality and difficulty of
taking over a show he also expressed
empathy for kutcher explaining that he
had done the same thing by taking over
from michael j fox on spin city luckily
sheen and kutcher appear to have put
their beef behind them when kutcher ran
into sheen at a baseball game the pair
even shook hands
out of all the characters in two and a
half men the most memeable was alan
harper from him constantly forgetting
his wallet to refusing to move out of
his brother's malibu beach house allen
was the ultimate sponge however chuck
lorre's initial vision for the character
of alan was very different from the one
that appeared on screen in fact he and
the show's co-creator lee aronson plant
something of biblical proportions in a
conversation with the hollywood reporter
laurie said alan was always designed
from the get-go to be kind of the
biblical job the good man who is trying
his best and can't catch a break and the
character has morphed over the gears and
become much broader the showrunner
admitted that while that was the plan
the character deviated from it as the
series found its feet charlie on the
other hand was supposed to be symbolic
of dionysus the god of wine and
fertility that one seems to have stuck
throughout
charlie harper had many lovers on two
and a half men but there were a select
few who almost tamed the wild man
one of these individuals was jennifer
taylor's character chelsea the actress
had appeared on the show in smaller
parts before being cast as chelsea in
season six
what many fans don't realize is how the
sitcom gave taylor the exact
professional and financial boost she
needed at the time while chatting with
entertainment journalist jeremy roberts
taylor opened up about how she had just
given birth to her daughter and was
preparing to sell her house to make ends
meet when she got the part she
considered the timing a good omen and
began filming for the recurring role in
2008
[Music]